this afternoon  following the passing of our late  sovereign queen elizabeth ii  our sadness at this time  is shared by people across the globe  as we remember with affection and  gratitude the lifetime of service  given by our longest reigning monarch  but the basis on which our monarchy is  built  has ensured  that through the centuries the crown has  passed in an unbroken line of succession  today's ceremony  marks a formal proclamation  to the people of district of stratford  on avon  the beginning our new king's reign  yesterday the accession council met at  james's palace to proclaim the new  sovereign  the flags which had flown at half masts  since the queen's demise  were raised briefly to their full height  to mark the start of his majesty's reign  the accession council also made an order  requiring the proclamation to be read in  the areas of their jurisdiction  and with my humble duty i know now read  the proclamation  to the people of the district of  stratford on avon